so I'm paraphrasing a bit I think you've
been quoted as saying you'd rather be
polarizing than having people just have
like this lukewarm reaction like yeah
she and Ryan's those films are okay but
you'd rather have somebody really feel
strongly one way or the other why is
that love your films or it's not for
them yeah because I mean if you just
think something's all right then you
forget about it you know I mean there's
been movies were I don't know if like I
hated them but I would never watch them
again like does one movie I saw called
family portraits i see i said i imaged
put it out actually i saw like 10 years
ago and I didn't hate it i just i hated
watching it you know it was sort of
disturbed me this really struck a nerve
and I was just like I've instantly gave
the movie away on to somebody else who I
thought might want to watch it i was
like i don't need it back you know I'm
never gonna watch this movie again but
you got to watch it you know versus
those other movies where was like that
was amazing and I have to keep watching
it but there was another movie again I
didn't hate it it's called them the
living and the dead I couldn't even get
through it it just it really just did
not make me feel good and and I've seen
plenty movies that don't make me feel
good or kind of disturbed me but this
just I don't know I explained it it just
really pissed me off um but I still went
out and bought just last week this is
years later you know they're like a new
movie that I saw by him because I'm like
okay I gotta try and watch this now
because like I thought he did such a
good job with what he's doing but um my
stomach was so out of that um I thought
he did you know a really good job with
the way he's doing it's just did not sit
well with me and that's what a lot of
people have told me but I rather my
movie not sit well with you then you
just be like I was cool because do I
ever talk about movies that I was like I
was alright I probably forgot about it
and you don't really want that as an
artist for a lot of reasons if somebody
absolutely loves or hates as fiscally
love it obviously you want the love
thing first but they absolutely hate it
they're going to talk about it that's
publicity so you and I've had to learn
to look at filmmaking from every angle
doing everything much you know on my own
you know for so many years it's like I
mean even you know distributing like
I've gotten in with distributors
learning that whole thing so I really
kind of learned I don't really know how
to do anything well but I know a little
bit about everything you know and so I'm
always looking at stuff from every angle
and if they hate it they're going to
talk about it and then they're going to
create discussion and debate I love
debate I actually went to college when I
tried to go to college when i was 18 i
went for journalism and i never liked
going to school so like we had a I never
did good and quizzes every quiz I failed
I think I got an F on every single quiz
but we were only graded two ways the
other way were graded was um we would
have to read these debates on you know
this versus that and then bright our
opinion on why we were so for something
or so against something and I didn't
read a single one of these debates I
just read the subject and I just bs'd
the whole thing and I never got lower
than a plus because I even got an extra
credit on some it a plus+ extra credit
you know and what that was that I just
love that idea of having such a strong
opinion I didn't even need to know it
was about that is could just find
something I'm tuned in and just go with
it you know and I think if people so
that doesn't hold the baiting thing so I
think if people have that just like all
these things we were told to read like
it just creates all that awareness you
know because it creates the base like I
saw some filmmaker the disgaea know Ryan
Nicholson who makes very gory films and
my films don't have any gore they are
all kind of psychological or there or
they have explicit nudity on you know
they're driven through like boy ism but
they're not gory so Ryan has a different
crowd but we but he's a co-producer on
my name is a so anyways he really loved
the amex reports or killer movies which
don't have a single drop of blood and
the whole trilogy and so he was
promoting those yet the other day on his
facebook and people to start going to
often about how much they hated it
because his fans probably all wanted to
see gore and then inked it
he'll drop of blood you know and but
that just created him now defending it
you know filmmakers you know more well
known and me now you know now defending
me so it just created this kind of
debate thing and why he liked it you
know I mean so like it just it just it
creates discussion and creates talk
raise awareness but on top of people
hating it because I doesn't like it then
there's people who hate it because they
don't want to face it and that's I think
more what i like is i think because of
my background everything that's happened
it's like I've had to deal with
since I was five years old that know
five-year-olds would have to deal with
that I've had to face like every day of
my life since and I had to face so much
as a kid I never felt like I got to
be a kid and so it's like I'm kind of
throwing out all my anger on screen and
you can't even deal with that if
I had to deal with this in real life you
better deal with it on screen you know I
mean it's like I guess this is that
confrontational attitude you know it's
like if somebody was raped and then they
made a movie about rape and somebody's
like oh I can't deal with that it's like
I'm you know like it like of a girl you
know made a movie about it you know rape
it's like how dares almost like how you
know dare somebody like know you better
face this this stuff happens it happened
to me what's this person get raped and
know that this happens you know and I
think that's what I do is you know it's
like this stuff happened to me or I'm
very aware of it and you don't want to
deal with it know you better you know
you better learn that that's out there
just face it you know I don't know if
that makes sense but it's just kind of
like I mean p I because I think if
people are more aware maybe what
happened as much or maybe people would
be more if people who have a heart at
least would be more willing to stop it
you know I just think
I guess as an awareness thing if people
is not like my movies going to change
the world it's not like I make a movie
thing is going to change the world but
you change people one person at a time I
think and if you make people go hey this
happens you just made me realize that
maybe from there something in start you
know for sometimes people don't like
stuff because it reminds them of
themselves like people that they say oh
I can't stand that person well times you
look at them and they're very similar
maybe they don't see it but it's so
sometimes people don't want to see stuff
about themselves thats dark well it's
funny because that's exactly what
happened with the amateur porn star
killer and a friend a chatty mentioned
there's documentary about it now this
guy we know Chad it was one of the very
first people to stand he was one of like
the first three people there's like
three guys who had who saw the movie
they're all like middle-aged guys who
saw it and just really stood behind it
and and she had specifically had said
that it made him question not only
himself but society you know he wondered
he said it basically he went into it
wanting sex and violence he got sex and
violence and then he got it in a way
where made him go what the hell is wrong
with me like why did I want to see that
it delivered on what I wanted to see but
in such a realistic way that it's like I
just got hit with reality that that's
not a good thing and what is wrong with
me that I actually was hoping to have a
good time watching that because I didn't
have a good time watching it and it made
him question the rest of society as well
you know and I think that that movie a
lot of the people who I think actually
liked the film did so they did because
they realized they needed to change
something about themselves or their way
of thinking and the people a lot of
people i think didn't like it didn't
like it for the same reason you know and
and then that that's another thing 20
people love or hate something that's
usually for the same reason i think
actually in a lot of ways you know the
people loved it and hated it
for the same reason either they loved it
because it you know spoke of that issue
or they hate it because it spoke of that
issue and that means that it's the issue
i guess not the film it's the issue or
it's the subject which I'm realizing
knows I'm saying but you know so maybe
that's it
you